pero precisamente las inmediaciones del
consejo nacional electoral en este sitio
que se ha dispuesto como un centro de
cómputo se mantiene al fondo en los
interiores de este lugar los seguidores
ya cooper es precisamente desde la noche
de ayer durante todo el día él
destacado que existe un supuesto fraude
en su contra todo esto porque según él
asegura habría sucedido una supuesta
reunión entre rafael correa mejor gen
nebot y distintos representantes
opositores hay agujeros donde
supuestamente él asegura que se estaría
en marca un presunto fraude estas
declaraciones han sido desmentidas por
parte de los consejeros del órgano
comicial lo cierto es que hasta el
momento va superior al 98
60 por ciento de las actas escrutadas ya
el 80% de los otros escaños los otros
puestos que se estarían de escrutando y
posesionando para la asamblea nacional
ya se han contabilizado así que el
consejo nacional electoral garantiza que
concluirán a tiempo para posicionar en
la fecha estipulada por la constitución
el 14 de mayo para los asambleístas
nacionales y el 24 de mayo para el
presidente de la república